hmm thanks now obviously I'm not
normally nervous when I do the show but
I do look at that couch and I think
trouble if I was a teacher I would not
sit you together
who's Jeremy did you have beef at some
point well a small beef Jun remember
years ago we went to don't remind him
do you remember he's Holland in ER oh
talent yeah me and basically some TV
except went round that way they were all
kind of like newsreaders where I went
around the table Jeremy was opposite me
and so let's start with you Joe how
would you improve the BBC and I said sac
Jeremy Clarkson I came back and said no
I ban all jokes about tampons which of
you up are you good you're good now no
we're fine oh good and Shannon you you I
think we meet you feud free you're not
shooting with anyone at the moment you
have no beef no no no only positive
energy into the universe very gross
scary luisina
not feeling the positive energy
no suppose the Gaga is the last one
that's what better the Gaga oh don't I
like my gardener yeah
gaga no she's lovely and are you getting
out of here with Simon now that's all
good I'll never see him so it's fine
got a picture the two of you had a
premiere there you are oh yeah you look
scary like a woman I had a one-night
stand with him Wiggin
and was me